people ask me all the time if i pull
practical jokes on my kids
yup
hey i came from an era of this
the people you made fun of the people
you pulled jokes on were the people you
liked i didn't waste time on jokes or
insulting people i didn't like this is
the community this is how we
communicated with each other i know it's
antiquated but right so when i pull joe
if i pull a joke on you i [ __ ] like
you
right and that's how that goes
and so i pull jokes on my kids but i
will people ask me a lot what's the best
practical joke you ever pulled on your
kids and i wish i could take credit for
this
but i didn't i didn't pull this joke on
them
i just let it happen
i take credit for it but they really did
it to themselves
so again this was when i was a single
dad and uh this was before i was dating
beth and we were poor man i made a
thousand dollars a month for three the
me and the three kids we all lived in
one room
and uh and listen guys you guys know
here in arizona there are times in the
summer where it's just too [ __ ] hot
to take your kids out to the park so
you're gonna find someplace indoors and
if you don't have money that means the
mall
a supermarket
we used to go to petco the kids love
petco right
oh they hated seeing us walk in there
like get every animal out [ __ ]
yeah
my oldest son used to play fetch with
jacob and they throw a ball across the
store and jacob
anyways
so
one day
we're there
and my daughter around six at the time
so my oldest son was trevor was eight
caitlin was about six puts jacob about
three
and caitlin walks up to me and she goes
[Music]
i want to ask you a question but i know
you'll say no
i go okay don't ask me she goes no i
want to ask you
i said okay ask me she goes okay okay
okay
now i know i didn't eat my breakfast i
know i know i didn't finish it and i
know i was supposed to finish my
breakfast and i will i'll finish it i
promise i finish it when i get home i
promise i finish it when i get home
but
can i have a cookie
and i said babe i
i don't have any cookies she goes no no
one of the petco cookies i go show me
show me what you're talking about
now for those of you who have never been
out of the [ __ ] house before
petco has
dog treats that look like little
chocolate chip cookies right
so she walks up and she goes
and i go you you
i could you
you want that cookie
[Music]
and she goes
and i said uh
okay
now jacob is made my breakfast
can i have a cookie
i said you
you want that cookie
anyone
[Music]
and i said
okay
now my eight-year-old is standing next
to me and he's staring at them but he's
talking to me out of the side of his
mouth and he just goes
that's dog food right
[Music]
and i said
yeah
and then i said to him i said
i set up
you want cookie
there he goes no
[Music]
the kids go to put the cookies in their
mouth like no no no we gotta eat those
in the car we can't eat those in here
i don't mind being a bad parent in
private just not in public you know what
i mean
get your [ __ ] together
[Applause]
everybody so we go out my oldest son and
i are in the front seat we're looking at
them in the rearview mirror like this
and they go to eat the cookie now look
anybody who has kids knows when this
cookie touches their lips before it even
touches their tongue before they taste
it what noise are they going to start to
make
that's right
and jacob it hit his lips and then he
would um and then it hit his tongue and
he went
now here's one thing guys i did not see
coming ready because here's we were poor
i made a thousand dollars a month yo a
treat was just that it was a [ __ ]
treat you didn't get them all the time
man and the rule was if you didn't
finish your treat
you never got another one of those
treats
i never i didn't think of these as
treats because it was a joke to me they
thought they were real cookies
so they just both just popped the whole
[ __ ] thing in their mouth
and i was like oh my god i didn't see
that coming holy [ __ ]
that was so much better than i could
have even imagined
and they just started to chew them just
[Applause]
now not only do i imagine that the taste
made it difficult to chew but guys i
want to promise you right now you know
what really made it difficult to chew
hey i'll tell you what if i gave you all
a piece of paper and a pen i said please
write down one word
that would describe these treats i
promise you not one of you would use the
word moist
they were just
they were [ __ ]
it was like i poured a bag of sand in
their mouth just [ __ ] well because
when i asked him how is it he said
pretty good like
[Music]
now let me can i tell you what my
favorite part about this joke is
yo i didn't tell him it was a dog treat
for three years
[Applause]
[Music]
he was too young to know i needed him to
know he ate a [ __ ] dog treat so he
had to be old enough
or what's the point of the joke and it's
just for me that's not good you know
now to be fair now be fair okay
they do like
at my house i'm the one who scares the
easiest
i'm the one i'm the one who scares the
easiest they scare me and just so you
know like at my house when you practical
joke somebody when you get somebody you
say gotcha
and they've all tried to get me back and
the only person that's never got me back
was jakey
and he's he's always like i've always
just wanted to say got you i've always
wanted to say got you you just got you
and you can't look man he's not he's
first of all he's too nice
he's too nice like you can't get me with
food i grew up with three older brothers
if you're too excited for me to eat
something there's no [ __ ] way i'm
eating that
zero he's tried to get me before with a
brownie he was like you want this
brownie
are you laughing no
you can't get me in a room because guess
who's not going into the room first me
i never go into her if someone's like go
in i'm like [ __ ] are you going
no i don't and here's another thing
i'm hard to prank because
i i know what my daily routines are
and if if something is bumped off i take
a mental note of it if more than one
thing is bumped off i assume somebody's
coming for me
[Music]
does anybody then anybody grow up in a
youngest of a big family
yo there's some ptsd that comes along
with that [ __ ]
so all right so i i don't trust anybody
in here okay
and so
this was his greatest attempt for the
go-to
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]